see the economic system in the world is
not a zero-sum game everybody can get
richer everybody can get richer if
everybody is more productive there's an
unlimited amount of human needs to be
met I mean you know it's it's it's like
there's thousands of millions of
billions of needs for housing healthcare
you know better better living standards
more this more that it's not like
there's some fixed pool of demand and
it's question of who can compete to
serve that demand there's this giant
pool of needs and if we can get more
productive everybody can get wealthy
you're in serving those needs and and
we've got this capacity to get used to
take you know 50 years for an economy to
grow learn and develop technology and
sophistication and therefore be able to
venture out in you know into the
international arena now we have massive
flows of capital and knowledge and
management and technology and and you
know my friend Jeff Sachs you know kind
of stole a title for I gave a lecture at
the Kennedy School about six or seven
years ago which way i think i think the
lecture was titled the end of poverty i
think he used that title and i think we
have in our reach the capacity to
eliminate these tremendous disparities
in different parts of the world if we
can harness these forces so so i think i
think these changes are our epic changes
you